[Music]
so i'm about to say the word that
inspires fear and loathing into the
hearts of tech spinners everywhere
toroids
what on earth is a toroid and why do
they have such a bad reputation that's
the topic of this video drex here from
drexfactor poi sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and today i'm
playing one of the old hits of the tech
poi world before we dive in i just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support for my
work and my mission so before anything
else we should probably start with the
obvious
what the heck is a toroid toroids are a
subset of plane bending moves that
involve moving the plane to the poi
around a circular hand path essentially
creating a donut like shape over which
the poi happens to pass
generally this is done in the fashion
that keeps the plane of the poi pointed
towards the audience to produce a linear
rather than circular profile the name
torade comes from the shape that the poi
travels the surface of namely
mathematicians refer to the shape of a
doughnut as a torus and transformations
of it as toroids hence the name that we
apply to these patterns in much the same
way that zan's diamond has come to be
shorthand for any pattern made of linear
extensions that traces the perimeter and
transits of a diamond with poi toroids
also became generalized over time to be
shorthand for just about any use of
plane bending with the edge of the poi
plane pointed toward the audience
whether the toroid shape was at the core
of this pattern or not but there were
considered to be three canonical types
of toroids that were essentially
applications of how we think of flowers
mapped onto a 3d space
these types are known as isobend
anti-bend and pro-bend i know this feels
like a lot of jargon but stick with me
for a second to understand what each of
these terms mean we're going to do
something kind of abstract think of
yourself holding a staff and proceed to
move it around in three different
patterns
an extension
anti-spin flower and inspin flower these
all map more or less onto things that
we're already familiar with in the poi
world now what if instead of a staff we
were instead talking about the plane of
a poi that is all the positions that the
poi goes through as it spins around your
hand i generally visualize this like a
hula hoop that hovers with my hand in
the center of it when the hula hoop is
seen on end by the audience it really
doesn't look that different from the
staff because they're seeing it
flattened down along one axis but from
another perspective we can see that
there are many positions the poi can be
moving through as our hand travels
around this path so think that an iso
bend toroid is moving the plane of the
poi in a manner similar to what our
staff extension looks like that is it
completes a single beat spinning in the
same direction that the hand does the
plane will always be at a right angle to
the path that the hand is moving through
this results in poi patterns where we
see the poi pass back and forth between
positions near the center and edges of
the toroid or donut an anti-bend toroid
involves spinning the plane in the
opposite direction that the hand is
moving in it's the equivalent of that
anti-spin flower we looked at with our
staff just a moment ago and when done
continuously results in patterns in
which the poi is always spinning along
the outside rim of the toroid or donuts
a probin toroid involves spinning the
plane in the same direction that the
hand is moving in but completing more
beats than the hand in the same amount
of time
this is the equivalent of that inspin
flower we did with the staff and results
in patterns where the poi is always
spinning along the center edge of the
toroid or donuts still confused i'd be
happy to do an overview video of just
the concepts behind these toroids alone
to explain them in more detail let me
know if you'd like to see that by
leaving a request in the comments this
may be the first time that you're
hearing the term or even being made
aware of the concept
so how did this bizarre corner of the
tech poi world go from ubiquitous to
practically unknown in just a few short
years first let's start with where they
came from there are several antecedents
for toroids including some of the plain
bent shapes that old school poi spinner
arashi was known for back in the late
2000s and a variety of different atomic
poi tricks but the vocabulary and theory
around toroids coalesced around a
handful of tech spinners in the
mid-atlantic region and new england back
in the summer fall and winter of 2010
including myself over the course of a
series of both in-person gatherings and
online posts
this small brain trust outlined the idea
of conceptualizing the plane of the poi
as a prop to be spun in its own right
and created a variety of shapes based in
this concept to share with the broader
poi world and this started a brief craze
in which toroids became one of the hot
moves in the tech poi world led by
contributions from charlie cushing eric
de guzman tom grigner and many others
toroids became both a hot commodity as
well as a framework that lots of tech
spinners loved to hate so the thing
about toroids is that they are extremely
difficult to do in a fashion that is
both clean as well as pleasing to the
eye
they require a type of movement and
relationship from the hand and poi that
is completely outside the normal skills
that one learns spinning traditional
flowers and weaves even learning to do
basic isobends the most intuitive of all
the patterns requires rewriting one's
understanding of where the poi is and
will be traveling to consequently a lot
of the work produced on the topic was to
be very charitable
a little inelegant you get lots of
videos featuring toroid-based tricks
where you had to have some fairly
detailed knowledge of the topic to
understand the spinner's intent
to those who weren't in on the idea a
lot of it just looked like straight up
gibberish there were outliers of course
eric de guzman's videos showcased toroid
versions of classic flowers that were
astoundingly clean and tim goddard found
ways to turn the unpredictability of
plane work and toroids into a feature
instead of a bug with his work on tape
deck toroids but there was a large part
of the tech poi community that looked at
the work being done with toroids and
simply opted out they hated how the
difficulty of the technique around it
resulted in so many sloppy patterns as
well as a name that
let's be real sounds uncomfortably like
hemorrhoids
2013 was the year the circus craze began
among american poi spinners and it
quickly resulted in even many of the die
hard toroid enthusiasts switching to
juggling 3-poi or other fashionable new
applications for tech poi in the ensuing
years with content related to toroids
running more or less dry by the
following year and i think it's a shame
personally i think there was a lot more
potential to explore interesting new
applications for poi
that just never really got it shot
because the techniques for achieving it
came with such a steep learning curve
jugglers always talk about the amount of
time necessary to train for each trick
and i can't help but wonder if someone
spent as much time grinding on toroids
as they did on seb's mess whether we
wouldn't have gotten some really
impressive new tech out of it but hey
maybe toroids are due for a comeback i
discovered several months ago that they
make for a great way to do timing and
direction changes that put less strain
on the shoulders than stalls do to say
nothing of the fact that many
dance-based poi styles happen in a much
more three-dimensional environment that
toroids might be a great fit for but
what do you think are toroids a lost gem
of the tech poi world that are due for
some rediscovery
are they a bizarre misfit that rightly
ended the first tech poi wave would you
like to see more content around them
leave me a comment and let me know in
the meantime i think i'm going to try
and work some more toroid practice in
for myself because i definitely have
been spending more time in 3d land the
past few years
who knows i might stumble onto something
great that i never knew was hiding there
in the first place
want to join me
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and help other people find this
video this video would not be possible
if not for the wonderful support of all
of these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support do you like my videos do you
like my flow sessions vlogs reviews
combos and more i'm on a mission to
bring poi spinning and flow arts to the
wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies so help me
do it head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you as it
turns out there are a whole lot of
videos i did on toroid's back in the day
so i'll go ahead and link to a playlist
of videos i did on the topic down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on youtube thank you so
much for watching and for going down
this rabbit hole with me make sure you
get out and flow today and i'll see you
with a new video real soon
peace